It is 8:00 p.m. 8:06 on a Saturday and
uh I figured I'd come back and do
another hour or so worth of
experiments to see if I can figure
something out with the model based
stuff.
So, I guess the first obvious thing is
why don't we just make it
bigger,
right?
Like just make it bigger. I doubt this
does anything.
Just do like four times input size
something like I
guess. See if that does
anything. Inconsistent yada
yada. I believe these both need to be
512.
I guess we just project the
um state embedding.
Maybe just project the
state. It's only the cell state that we
need to project, right?
It's like really annoying to actually
make this bigger, isn't
it? That's like really annoying.
I could make them both a bit bigger just
for now. That's probably pretty easy,
And then we got to start really looking
at all the losses and seeing if I've
done stuff wrong.
Let's look at the uh the call to the
model
much. So this is the uh actual logic of
it. 32
forwards, actions and log
props computed from original
logits. And then we call the world model
on those
actions and the current state.
which is formed
by the observation embedding and the
current LSTMC
state. That could be zero to be fair. We
could just set that to
zero because you never get it at
um at train time come to think of it.
says
160 episode return. So that's still very
very
low. You add the
rewards to this
Next thing I'm going to try is zeroing
the LSTM.
Try
this since I believe when we're training
it, we never get out of
Okay. I'm also if we need to train it
with like shorter
segments since it only rolls out
five. Could be we need to train it with
shorter segments.
I could technically train it on length
one
segments. I don't think that's what we
want to do, right?
I really was hoping we could get this
thing to work today.
I mean, I rather like this over the
dreamer style
formulation. Uh, this is lower score
actually though than the
previous, isn't
it? So, maybe there is something to
What? Can we just like roll this out one
and then get something to
train? Like it technically even if you
roll out one step it should be better.
Quick question. What are the essential
methods that need to be implemented for
an
ocean? So we have squared as like our
default
and needs a step
method, needs a reset
method, probably should have a render
and a
close. But the thing is
like, yeah, technically these have to
exist for the new bindings that we're
adding, but other than
that, I mean, there's a Python anyways.
You just call this stuff from Python.
squared. It's like a kind of like a
vectorzed gym
interface. I have them both in the same
file. C step reset C render. Yeah,
that's what we use at the moment. Now
you're catching us in between binding
methods here. Um because like what we're
trying to do is instead of having Syon
We're trying to have like this type of a
binding where you can write this instead
of Syon. This is way shorter and
easier. Yeah. Then you just check the
Syon. If you're just doing the Sython,
then the names literally really don't
even matter because like you just make
sure that they match, right? Because
you're just calling the Syon from
Python. There's like no fancy special
binding for the Sython. It's just like
whatever binds to C. If you just like
copy the way we've done it with the
other Ms, you'll see like there's no
magic. What methods are expected from
the Python code? Okay, that's a
reasonable one.
So if you just look at the environment,
right? This is what we do. Whoops, wrong
one. So we have this thing for puffer
end. This is the entire code. Um these
are handled for you. It just needs a
reset, a step, and a close. That's
it. Your Sython can expose whatever you
want, right? It's the Python has to have
a reset, a step, and a
close. But like I would suggest just
doing it the way you see that we have
our M's done here. It's a pretty good
way of doing it. Like so here's the
squared M. So this is like a pure
Python. Uh where is it? This is the new
binding example here. This is the Sython
one. Logging is just for displaying
stats. Yeah, the stuff that pops up here
when I run experiments that you see, it
comes from here.
So like this is the example with Syon
here,
right? It's a render method. It just
calls
render step. The only gotcha here,
right, is that you have to init with
this buffer and then this buffer set
selfobservations actions. It sets all
these things
up and then these are like shared
buffers.
So like this data gets shared between
the Python, the C and the Python because
it's just the same memory
address. And like you see how we
populate the actions here. We do self
actions equals
actions. And then the step doesn't take
any arguments. That's because we already
told that this is the action tensor.
Here's the memory where the actions are
going to be. And then we just put these
into memory. So when it steps, it knows
that they're here. That's the only
tricky bit. The rest is pretty
self-explanatory. And if it's not, you
come back to
me. I will be live back again most of
Monday break
out. Yeah. So you check the snake emb if
you want. I wrote the snake emb. It's a
lot more concise. I didn't write pong or
breakout. Oh, you're still doing voids.
That's awesome. Um, yeah, we were
actually just check talking about that
because like we were thinking of doing
like flocking type stuff more broadly
with puffer. It'll be
cool. What should the agents go
actually? If you just look up voids,
right? You just turn these rules into
rewards.
like you'll find the rules somewhere
like
this. Yeah. So, what they do here is
they like they code these behaviors. All
you would do is you turn these into
rewards. Coherent separation alignment
agent be a predator. It doesn't have to
be. You literally just like give it.
So this is like what they try to do
here. If you find the algorithm code
like look see somebody has a really big
one
here. It's pretty cool
right? I think it's following my cursor
in this one.
agent schools to adjust the params. I
the way so vids is a rulebased system
originally, right? So like they will
just they have like a deterministic
rule-based behavior. So the agent the
actions are just going to be like turn
left, turn right or whatever by a
certain amount and uh you just give them
a reward for like aligning with nearby
agent, being coherent, whatever.
like yeah, this is a decent article
because look this here it has
um a description of the algorithm. So
you can pretty easily see how to adjust
this for a
reward. See like this is cohesion. this
is how they script it to like do this
and then you just think okay well
cohesion is defined by how close bird is
to other bird or whatever give reward
that's
it and if you get stuck let me know but
definitely go try that
first will be an agent so think of it
this way, right? Just think of
everything in terms of actions. Okay? So
in the original voids, there are rules
that tell the agent which way to turn,
right? In your case, instead of giving
it rules for which way to turn, the
neural net gives it an action, which is
which way to turn. And the way that it
decides that action, right? or learns
what action it should take is you
convert the stuff like that before it
was saying uh turn so as to cohhere with
other agents or align with other agents
or whatever. Just turn those scripted
rules into rewards so it learns to do it
RL. And it's a lot more flexible too,
right? Because like scripting behaviors,
you have to be able to precisely script
for what happens in what circumstance.
Um, RL's a lot fuzzier because you just
give it a
reward. Yeah. The traditional rules
become the rewards.
Exactly. Yeah. This one like don't
overthink it. It should be a very very
simple end. I intentionally gave this
one to you because I think it's a very
simple amp that has the potential to
look very cool if you do it well.
Syon binds.
So how S Python like Syon is just an
intermediary layer. Look, there isn't
really an API for anything except like
the actual Python environment has to
have a step, a reset, and a whatever,
right? the Syon and the C. It's not
really an API, at least until we go to
the new binding stuff. It's just like
you write the end code and then whatever
methods you need to call, you call them
via the Sython. I suggest doing it with
like step, reset, render, whatever the
way we have it because it makes it
easier, but like it's kind of just a
convention. It's just like what we've
found to make it easier. We structure
stuff that way.
Client client is the renderer. Client is
like the front
Yeah, in Syon it's
not the Syon just like makes makes an
instance of it. So it'll
render. Look, it's going to be way clear
if you just look at the snake end. Oh
we, it rounded to 2K
stars. That's
awesome. That's cool.
Uh, that's really
nice. There are not that many RL repos
this
big. Look, so the snake amp is really
simple, okay?
Like the client is like a screen of
code, right? It's got this render
function. That's all it does. The client
just has a couple like properties.
That's it. And then like the Sython is
just this is just a header, right? This
is just a header.
And then this makes all the items right
here. Pulls a net. Reset step render.
Close. That's
it. And this client here, this make
client that is literally just makes a
renderer. That's all it is. And this
make function is just a C
function. Python's just an easy way to
expose C methods to Python. That's all
it is.
I've been trying to replace Syon, not
because necessarily the Sython's hard.
It's just it's more annoying to debug
Syon than it is to debug straight C.
Straight C is very easy to
debug, provided you're compiling with
address sanitizer at least.
defr there's literally no reason. It's
just me being lazy, not not liking
having It's me being lazy doing it in
two lines because I don't like having to
read all the way to the bottom to have
the to see where the name of this truck
is. There's no good reason.
Yeah, you can do it's like some of the
conventions are there for a good reason
and some of the conventions are there
because it's like I I wrote Python for
10 years and then started doing this
like a few months ago, like maybe six
months ago or whatever and like I'm
still finding better ways to uh to write
like clean concise
C. So, possibly I'll just get used to
having this rock name at the end. It
kind of annoys me that it's not at the
top because the trucks can get really
big, but
like model
state start working around not messing
around in demos? Yeah. Have a nice
evening. I'm going to bed soon. I just
want to see if I can try one or two more
things to maybe get this thing to work.
right? Oh, hang
on. New
Let's make
sure this should be a really good way to
test
should be the
value. I think the value is just the
value
I think it's just predicting the value,
isn't
it? Or is it new value? Hang on. New
value should be
predicting return,
right? Isn't this just return?
Okay, so this does better, but the value
law sucks.
I don't know why this would not work.
Very
weird. Logic reward value state, right?
Logit's reward value state. Yep.
crashed. Pretty damn sure that they
should have
this. I'd be kind of surprised if that
made the difference.
guess why wouldn't you be able to
predict this is my question.
supposed to give you
logits, reward, value, and
state. That make any bloody sense?
action. No, you have this completely
wrong. This doesn't make any bloody
sense. All right. I think I just got
tired doing this.
I think I'm going to call it a night.
I'm like too tired to fully finish this
stuff. We made some good progress. Um,
we
got it like it's not like we've gotten
nothing to train all day. We've gotten
plenty of things to train. We just can't
beat the odd policy. have to be pretty
careful about the implementation for
that. Um, I'm still not completely sure
about this versus other world model
based approaches. I mean, I really like
this one in theory. I just don't know
how much compute this uses.
like
Efficient zero.
Okay. So, there is a thing. We should
probably look at
this. Look at efficient zero
next. This will like there's some
improvements.
Okay. Well, this is [ __ ] less wrong.
God damn
it.
Whatever. We'll actually check the
proper paper at some point. Um, I'm
getting some
sleep. All the
things.ai try to get up to help us out.
Go in
Discord. Follow me on X for more RL
content. Thanks. And I will be